so i wanted to create a relatively short
video
on things that you can do to improved
inflamed
colon so whether you have some type of
irritable bowel syndrome
or diverticulitis or crohn's or celiac
here are the most important things to
focus on number one
this is the obvious one avoid gluten
and grains for that matter because this
protein
gluten can really tear up the inside
part of the lining in your colon i would
also avoid dairy because
chances are if you have inflammation in
the colon you probably have
allergies and casein
in the dairy is one of the top allergies
that people have and so if you do dairy
it's going to also create
inflammation so we want to avoid
anything that you have an
allergy to number three limit the amount
of vegetables
if you have an inflamed colon you're
going to have
altered microbiome so you're not going
to have the balance of friendly
bacteria in your colon that means that
when you consume the vegetables and you
get the fiber
those microbes are going to get
overwhelmed pretty easily and
that is going to create a lot of
bloating so you
definitely need to adjust your
vegetables way down to the point where
you have
no more irritation in your colon
normally if you have a healthy colon
with all the microbes you can handle a
lot of
vegetable and in many situations i may
even recommend
to do carnivore for a while if you can
digest
protein if you can't you're gonna have
to build up your stomach acid to break
down that protein but there are a lot of
people especially if you have an
autoimmune disease
that's related to the colon they do very
well in carnivore
at least for a couple months so you can
heal the body and
then gradually add some more vegetables
into the diet
and it's very very important to avoid
vegetable oils which really vegetable
oils are not even vegetable oils they're
grain oils or seed oils
so avoid those like the plague because
they're high in omega-6
and they're very inflammatory okay soy
oil corn oil cottonseed oil
canola oil safflower oil
low-quality olive oil could be a problem
all very damaging for an inflamed colon
and of course the obvious don't consume
alcohol
or smoke believe it or not smoking
really depletes you of
certain nutrients vitamin c especially
and so when you don't have that
antioxidant in your body
you get more inflammation number five
chlorophyll chlorophyll is like the
blood of the plant if you're not
consuming
the vegetables to get the chlorophyll
which is the green from the plant
then do a concentrated chlorophyll you
have wheatgrass
powder which has some chlorophyll in it
but it has the fiber in there which
actually could irritate the colon
but if you were to do a wheatgrass juice
powder
that is the chlorophyll in the
wheatgrass without the fiber
that will work great because the
chlorophyll is very very healing
to the inside of the colon and i would
add that with water and consume that on
an empty stomach
two or three times a day wheatgrass
juice and i like it in a powder
is one of the best things to help heal
the inside
lining throughout your body number six
is a very interesting
product you're gonna have to look up the
brand
but actual intestines with stomach this
is a supplement
it's from grass-fed cows but
if you have an inflamed colon
chances are you may have some type of
auto-antibodies antibodies that are
attacking your own tissue
and what this product will do it will
greatly
help you when you consume it in a
capsule
form when it hits the stomach
the antibodies will go after
that as a decoy and leave your
intestines
alone and it's going to give you a lot
of relief
so i would start out taking one capsule
right before
bed number seven purify bile salts
very very important your
liver makes primary bile salts and your
microbes make secondary bile salts so if
there's some type of inflammation in
your colon
you're going to also have a problem
recycling
bile salts so you're usually going to be
deficient bile salts are necessary
to keep the junctions of your colon
tight and secured to prevent leaky gut
but bile salts can really help to
regulate the balance of microbes in your
gut
and they really seem to help people with
an inflamed colon
as well as people that have constipation
it keeps things flowing through the
liver and the gallbladder and the
intestines
okay number eight this is like essential
fasting
vitally important if you are too thin
and you have an inflamed colon and you
don't want to lose any weight
i understand that may be a problem so
you're going to have to
possibly take nutrients while you fast
and maybe do it
periodically but definitely do
intermittent fasting to some degree
like two meals a day ideally one meal a
day
and even periodic prolonged fasting but
fasting is
one of the best things to stimulate
stem cells in your colon to
heal the lining of the of the intestines
this right here is
very beneficial what's very bad for for
an inflamed colon is frequent eating and
snacks
all through the day and then lastly a
good probiotic
that can survive the stomach acids get
in the system
and repopulate the microbes that you
have in your
colon there you have it and if you have
not seen my video
on digestion i put it up right here
check it out
you